but not on his head
so
lock your body
like here you're okay walking onto me
so you see how i can push you
that meant you could walk
or you could walk
yes
lean on me
who did it i did you did it see
what
try to go out
because you still eat eating
you fell you need me
you follow the indians
you're in early
in energy
[Music]
the connection right
but people do different things so
he's going to do something
what are you gonna do okay he said he
turns in do you see there goes
here
turn
[Music]
get tired old man
i feel uh i feel that but you can see
it's gonna go off right you're gonna
feel the yin
you see find the
next control point
variation again
[Applause]
variation
play play with the energy
um
you can't learn the art by
staying on railroad tracks
you have to get off
adventure
so you don't have a stylistic preference
you have
an energetic
footprint
so
throws happen
because somebody
[Music]
is capturing
your ground vectors that's when you
throw
when they're not capturing your ground
vectors
it's because they're not really
coming after you they've gone defensive
they've gone in
and you therefore enter okay
so you have
a concept of
uh resistance it's easy standing up
straight
do you see well my feet are not
preoccupied so if you don't
see
don't find a throw for a stylistic
prejudice okay you won't feel
the energy she's doing it again you see
well i could enter
right here disengage
she let go
oh
and you should do that
because somebody who's still holding on
can't and has energy
i can't
i mean i give her back what she had you
see
so i don't give a
you do that one again she left up
you let
let go right boom
right you let go last time
do you feel that i have there she let go
oh you're in
okay
you're not here
you let's go
and you're trying to do a throw
this engaged
whoa
again it's disengaged you see with all
that wiggle and no nothing
okay
[Music]
it's because you learned your throws
you protect against throws
but you don't do that that's a stylistic
prejudice
you provide energy
because no energy
is defensive
okay you feel safe because
the prejudiced nagit wants to throw you
but the nagi who knows strife
is just gonna look for that every single
time
okay
try it again
okay so as zoo kid
i have to establish that organization
but there's a larger organization that i
have to stage and it still works off of
the center of periphery and silver i'm
so also
it still works off the light and dark it
still works off the light of defense and
offense okay so so far
as i'm okay
i have that center connection
in my hands
so when i come through don't move
and i do my technique
i have i touch that spinal displacement
okay
not here and nothing and not walking and
doing it
well my house touched
my hands touch goes right into the
center
because it's in my center okay because
my
weight
the energy is on my foot vector
which is in his foot vector okay
so
uh
how can he come in and strike when i'm
touching him like that do you see so
like he can't so let's say he makes his
arm really relaxed it doesn't matter
so he feels that
so you can't just kick or hit
he's gonna
uh
use that energy against me okay got it
so when he feels the projection that's
where his yield goes right but i'm back
in his feet
[Music]
not just here with me
i'm in his body
right from this touch
this touch is in his body
well it's not that i'm leaning on him
it's just at this point where i touch
is in his body okay so if he goes to
strike
right he can't come forward right
he goes to strike i'll feel the energy
i'll feel that in space go to stride and
i feel the space
you see and then i'm in
he'll feel preoccupied
so he has to carry the energy around oh
you see stay there
but if i again go weak
right which is
maximized by letting go you're free
again do you feel that
do me your hands
right
and my center is in my hands it's in his
ground power again so if he goes to
strike i'll feel it again
i'll feel it again
okay
so i preoccupied him and hence
he has
his throat
which is different from this
you see that difference
[Music]
and what do you notice about your camera
is it the same every time
it's different every time
okay
so he has to do something different
every time
and i do something different every time
and now it's not
railroad tracks but it is kiwamosa
try it again